[Music]
hello and welcome to Stanford Graduate
School of Business
my name is Sawyer Clark and I'm a first
year MBA here at the GSB some of my
classmates and I are going to show you
around our campus today as we walk
forward
we're walking away from the GSB
residences which are just across the
street in that direction and we're
heading into what's called the town
square this is very much the center of
and the lifeblood of our community
you'll see people all around me
meeting both students faculty classmates
of mine as well as guests or other
people that are affiliated with the
school to my left you also see Cooper
cafe which is a coffee shop with many of
my friends and myself meet to get coffee
between or before classes above Cooper
Kafka are many of the faculty offices as
well as the adverb wall of change which
describes the many ways we can change in
life tomorrow right is our buffle cafe
which is the main dining hall for all
the students at the GSP
[Music]
my name is Karla Lehren I'm an MBA one
students used the bass library mostly
for studying and also for group projects
I like to go to the bass library to get
my case readings done before classes and
I also go weekly for leadership coaching
from my arbuckle leadership hello my
name is Bo Scottie I'm an MBA to cluster
the GSD are taught by both practitioners
and tenured faculty to provide both
research and industry perspective what's
great about the GSP is that we don't
have any one method of teaching we have
several there are of course the case
methods and the lectures but we also
have a ton of experience and learning
opportunities where we apply concepts
learned in class into actual projects we
don't just learn in a traditional
classroom there are a lot of hands-on
learning opportunities many of these
courses take place at the coal lab where
in fact I'm headed next
hi my name is Taylor Nesbitt and I'm an
MBA one there at Stanford GSB the Kolob
is a community space where Stanford GSB
students and their co-founders can come
together to work on their startups it's
also an innovation hub for any Stanford
student can get exposure to design
thinking the collab is home to classic
Stanford startup classes like startup
garage and venture studio and huge
companies like door - have kept them in
one of my favorite companies that's
being worked on right now is called
praxis lab it's a diversity and
inclusion startup that uses AR and VR to
help engender empathy and others one of
the best parts about the collab is that
it's open 24/7 so when the coffee shop
is closed
and work on their startup together here
I'm trying to out look at the a
second-year MBA students from India we
are here at the Arbuckle dining civilian
at the center of the GSD with its indoor
and outdoor seating this part serves as
a natural meeting point for me and my
friends as we catch up over lunch or
dinner discussing our future working on
our class projects and thinking about
our carriers one of my favorite memories
here is catching up with my classmates
learning about their cultures and
cuisines while we share lunch or dinner
Arbuckle has a variety of options to
choose from ranging from grilled items
pizzas salads daily changing global
cuisine seasonal soaps and fresh fare I
love that Arbuckle also serves Indian
food something that I thought I would
miss when I move here right outside our
buckle is the monument to change art
installation it reminds me that the
future is always changing and I have got
to be evolving to change lives change
organizations and change the world
hi I'm Renata gorilla and I'm an MBA one
here at the GSB I'm originally from
Brazil and I moved here from Australia
Stanford students are known for whenever
we have the chance we go outside and
study for meetings for preparing
presentations we always reading and
doing maximizing our time outside which
is really great I didn't realize that
being GSB campus would be so integrated
with where most of the people live so
it's awesome that we can go to class go
to meetings go to speaker events host
small group dinners everything within
the same small radius so there is no
typical day here the GSB what I love the
most about living here at Jeff McDonough
Hall is that not only super close to the
GSB campus but it creates this amazing
beautiful sense of community
after a typical day here at the GSB I
like getting to my room and taking the
time to really shut down and I usually
do that by journaling and right
my day my name is Abbi oh don't worry
the good thing about Bailey just be
students he's being able to take classes
at any school at Stanford University it
gives you the opportunity to explore the
Stanford campus at Stanford Graduate
School of Business you are more than a
student you're part of the vibrant GSB
community from your classroom experience
to your active social life from forging
great relationships with classmates and
faculty to becoming part of the larger
Stanford network you'll find endless
possibilities we hope to see you here